ROMAIN GUY: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm all Romain Guy,
ADAM POWELL: I'm Adam Powell.
JIM SPROCH: And I'm Jim.
ROMAIN GUY: All right, and we're
here to talk about UI patterns.
Funny, a lot of you are
interested in that suddenly.
So there was a stealth
title for the talk,
so obviously it's about Jetpack
Compose on [INAUDIBLE] UI
toolkit that we're
working on, and that's
available in open source.
And so we want to talk a
little more about this today.
But first we want to talk
a little bit of history
and explaining why
we're doing this.
So how did we get here?
A lot of you obviously
are familiar with views
and activities and fragment, and
I'm sure you love those APIs,
they're close to perfect.
So just to give you a
little bit of background.
So this is a diagram that
Chad did for a talk that
we gave, I think, last year.
Shows you a timeline of what
we've been up to, especially
on the Android Toolkit team.
So after we shipped
Android 1.0, we
didn't do anything
for many, many years.
And then we finally
woke up and decided
to write new
libraries to help you.
So things like Recycler
View, Constraint Layouts,
Arch Components, and of course,
we had the adoption of Kotlin.
So we have been
working on new things,
but one things we
one thing we never
changed was the
UI toolkit itself.
We did a lot of work
underneath to make it better,
we had hardware acceleration,
we fixed some bugs,
we added some bugs, we
added a few features,
but we never changed
it fundamentally.
So one of the things that
happened over 10 years ago
was this.
This is a device that
we call the Sooner,
and this was the
first device that I
used to write Android
code when I joined Google.
So to give you an
idea, this device
had a single CPU
running at 80 megahertz.
It didn't have a GPU.
We had 64 megs of RAM, and
the screen was 320 by 240.
This was not the first
device that we shipped.
We shipped the G1, which
was slightly better,
but that was similar in spirit.
We shipped it with the GPU.
We mostly didn't use it.
So [INAUDIBLE] toolkit
was pretty much design
for this device.
Fast forward a few
years, and now we
have this kind of devices.
So this is a Pixel 2, I believe,
and the screen resolutions now
are 2160 by 1080 or 2960
by 4040 on the XL variants.
And here you can see a
screenshot of the Sooner
at the same scale, and
it fits comfortably
over just one icon
on the launcher.
So we're still using
the same UI toolkit,
so maybe it was time
to rethink our approach
to UIs to better
serve those devices.
And on top of that, so we build
the architecture components
over the past couple years,
and the approach we took
was extremely interesting.
We were more open.
We did a lot of alphas
and betas and RCs.
We talked with you,
the community, a lot
to hear what you wanted from us.
I mean, you build
the applications.
We don't really anymore,
so we need your input
to know what it is you
need, what is you want,
what are the problems that
you're facing every day.
So, yeah, what are
you asking for?
And what would
you like us to do?
So when we ask this
question for the UI toolkit,
in particular, one
of the answers we got
was unbundle the UI toolkit.
Because until now,
every time we wanted
to ship a fix in the UI
toolkit, or every time
we went to ship
a new feature, we
could do this easily
ourselves, but then you
had to wait for just
a few years to be
able to raise your
main API level.
And I know I've had many
discussions personally
with some of you where I said,
I fixed your bug, you're like,
yeah, I don't care
because the fix is not
going to reach my users'
devices for a long, long time.
So, not helpful at all.
So we are thinking about moving
some of our widgets to Jetpack,
make them be a support library.
Let's take text view, move
it entirely in Jetpack,
and then we'll be
able to deliver fixes.
But as we were thinking
about doing this
we thought, well,
if we're going to do
this, how about
we start improving
those widgets a little bit.
What could we do to
improve the APIs?
And I'm sure you all love
the APIs of our UI toolkit,
but as Chad put it, API design
is building future regrets.
And we have a lot of regrets--
a lot, even more than you do.
Here are some examples.
So for instance view.java,
do you know how big it is?
I'm sure you have big
files in your source code,
I'm pretty sure you don't
have files as big as this one.
So we have almost 30,000 lines
of code in view.java, yeah.
[APPLAUSE] That is Google's
[? scale ?] right here.
To be fair, it's
a lot of comments
but still this is
not very good design.
So that's one thing.
And then there's random stuff.
For instance, Spinner.
Why do we have this
class called Spinner?
It's a combo box or dropdown.
We don't like Spinner, nobody
does, and a bunch of people
ask, why is it called Spinner?
I'll show you why.
So when we shipped
our first SDK,
this is what it looked like.
So I ran this on my
Mac, and it does spin.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're not entirely
crazy or stupid,
we just changed our mind.
Another example that I
really like is Button.
Button, if you look at the
source code of button.java,
it's extremely interesting.
There's very few
lines of code in there
because it extends TextView.
Why?
It's a good question.
Because when you
need to display text,
the problem is that TextView
can do a lot of things.
For instance, you can make a
button selectable if you want,
and I'm pretty sure you
can also make it editable.
[LAUGHTER]
All right and of
course, there are
tons of other issues
but Adam who's
going to talk more about those.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah,
Romain told me
that I had to take
the slide that
started with fragments here.
I'm not entirely sure why.
So as you stop to factor
some of your UIs on Android,
and you start to have to
make some decisions about how
you're going to write
your UI components.
And this is a question that
we've had a lot over the years.
Do I write a fragment or do I
write a custom view or custom
viewgroup?
And the problem with this
is that the answer can
be really different depending
on the kind of component
that you're writing,
and each approach
has some of its own challenges.
For example, if you
see this line of code
somewhere because someone
decided that they were going
to write a custom view to
solve a particular problem,
what exactly is
your first reaction?
ROMAIN GUY: Awesome.
JIM SPROCH: No, Romain.
ADAM POWELL: No?
OK, so custom views are kind of
daunting to write because you
really have to get
so many things right,
especially if you want to expose
a first class API surface.
You've got properties that
need their getters and setters,
pretty standard stuff.
You've got XML
attributes, which means
that you need to start adding
in more stuff in your attrs.xml,
define styleables.
Speaking of stylables, you need
to define actual default styles
and probably edit some
default theme attributes
to make sure that all those
styles get wired up properly.
And that's before you even get
to the sheer volume of code
that you need for dealing with
things like layout or touch
events.
So meanwhile, fragments give
you a whole lot of flexibility,
plus all the lifecycle hooks for
hanging your application logic
from, especially now that
you've got arch components
to give you some of this
in a more pluggable way.
But this kind of
makes them better
suited for coarser
grained situations.
Reusable hold article displays
with interactive subcomponents
and not really so much
things like single buttons.
But the problem with this is
that your apps aren't static.
They really change
and grow over time.
So there's a potentially
really high engineering cost
to having to cross
over from one of
these abstractions to another
as your use cases change.
So you insulate yourself
from that change.
You build other
architectures to keep
your views, your fragments,
and activities as removed
from these things as
possible, and maybe
actually make it a little bit
easier to test along the way.
No matter which of these
architectures, or some of them
that aren't listed
that you might choose,
they all take on the
same basic shape.
You bind some of this
stuff in your activity,
your views publish
events and receive state,
and everything in between
is kind of a judgment call.
So these architectures
really exist
to help define and reason
about your apps' data flow
and answer the three
main questions.
So what is the source of truth?
Who owns it?
And more specifically,
who can change it?
So once you answer some
of these questions,
then you realize that
the Android UI toolkit
doesn't really work this way.
Views kind of own
their own state
and make their own changes
whether you want them
to or not.
Most of these view
state changes at least
have some optional
listeners that you
can attach so you can respond
to some of those changes
and do something about it.
But really, the Spinner is
another great example here,
as odd as it is.
And it's got this
onSelectedItemChanged listener
that tells you when the
user changed the value.
You've picked a new
value from the dropdown.
And it gives you this callback
after the items already
changed.
And for a lot of UIs,
this is kind of useless
because then you have to
change it back after the fact.
So if you've ever
created one of those UIs
where you have a custom dot,
dot, dot, you pop up a dialog,
you've let the user make
some custom selections,
and then you have to
change the adapter,
set the value to something new.
It's kind of a song and dance
that's not a lot of fun.
And you also have to
deal with this idea
of these reentrant
listener calls
once you do set something back.
So your listener has to
handle both the cases
where you meant to
change it on purpose
or when the user did it.
And that just is more and more
code that you can get wrong.
But there's some advantages
to this kind of approach.
I mean, like, I
would love to just
be able to change my salary and
then tell Romain all about it
after the fact.
ROMAIN GUY: We'll
talk about it at work.
ADAM POWELL: No, this is me
telling you after the fact.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah,
we'll talk about it.
ADAM POWELL: OK.
So speaking of events, when you
have a single source of truth,
you don't have all
of these problems.
Every piece of
state has one owner.
And only the owner
can make changes
to that particular state.
So that means that
the owner is listening
to events that are happening
somewhere else in the UI,
and it makes
changes in response.
How many of you have
seen some code like this?
Hopefully, not too recently--
oh no, we've got a few hands.
OK, so Android's UI APIs
were really kind of designed
for this world--
handling events by implementing
several different listener
interfaces in one class
where that state lives.
By implementing these
interfaces where the state is,
you can make sure
that you don't have
to lace that state through
too many different places.
And this is kind of gross,
but lambdas weren't even
part of the language when
this was common practice.
So we can take a
few liberties here.
But if you let somebody who's
comfortable with Kotlin lose,
they might go nuts
and play some golf.
They might write
something more like this.
And the advantages of
something like this
is that it's event
driven and it's
built on composing
behaviors rather than based
on inheritance.
You can kind of get
away with implementing
a bunch of interfaces
on a central class
like the slide we saw before
when you have a small team.
If everybody fits
in the same room
and you can just ask
each other questions,
you know that you're
not going to make
a mess in front of one another.
But as app and
team sizes grew, it
became much less
sustainable to do that.
So by leaning into
Kotlin in particular,
we can write much more powerful
and more composable APIs.
But really, whether
you've decided
to write a fragment
or a view, the changes
that you have to
make really kind of
look similar if you're trying
to write something that's
really reusable, something
that exposes a first class API
surface for other people to use.
You'll have something that looks
either MyFragment or MyView,
and it might be a
Kotlin or a Java file.
You have an XML file
that holds your layout
for that particular
file potentially,
if it's something
complicated, if it's something
more than just a simple
button that clicks.
You've got some stuff in
your attrs.sml file that
defines the stylable and
all the different attributes
that it can take.
And you also have to
make sure that you
don't step on that
shared namespace
that resources work in.
Can't declare two attributes
for two completely different
stylables if they
have a different type.
That would be silly.
And then finally, you have
to deal with everything
around styling.
So you're spreading
all of this code that
really has to do with
the same component
across many different files.
And by breaking that
spatial locality,
it makes it harder to regain
context or flow at a glance
after you've been interrupted.
So for example, if you
have pets or small children
or an open plan
office, you might
get interrupted pretty often.
So really we're trying to
address all of these things
at once.
So first off, we
want to make sure
that we unbundle from
the platform releases
so that you can take
advantage of what
we're working on immediately.
We want to make sure that you
have fewer technology stack
flow charts to traverse
when you're deciding
how to build your component.
We want to make sure that
we're not telling you, well,
if you're doing something
that's bigger like this,
start with a fragment,
otherwise a button.
And if you're not sure, flip
a coin, see how it goes,
maybe refactor later.
We want to help you clarify
state ownership and event
handling.
This is really big
because this is
one of those things that
ends up being almost
an afterthought in some
applications if you are not
thinking about it upfront.
But it's really the flow of
data through your application
that can be the most
complex interactions.
And finally, we want help
you just write less code.
So the simplest program
that you can write in Kotlin
is really, really simple.
So whenever you're
writing a GUI app though,
they're not this kind
snapshot in time.
It's not a fire and
forget construct
where you run it once and
then the program terminates.
You're done, it's done its job.
So we kind of need to handle
this idea of an event loop
and things that
change over time.
And Kotlin really gives
us some huge advantages
for working with
asynchronous code now.
But can we go even further?
Can we make it as simple as
this to write an Android app?
JIM SPROCH: Well, maybe we can.
What if instead of calling
print line, we called text?
What if calling text
would admit a text widget
to the UI hierarchy?
This is the idea
behind Jetpack Compose.
It's a declarative UI
toolkit built for Android.
It's inspired by frameworks
like React, Litho, Vue.js,
and Flutter, but it's
written completely in Kotlin
and is fully compatible with the
existing Android view system.
It aims to simplify the
way that you write code
by making your Android UI
hierarchies more declarative.
With Compose, your UI is
defined as a function,
and this function transforms
data into view hierarchy.
In this case, the
input is a simple piece
of data, a person's name, and
the output is a UI hierarchy,
is a text widget.
When you need to
update the name,
we can just re-invoke this
function with the new data,
and the UI hierarchy will
contain a text widget
with the new text.
This radically simplifies
your application
because you no longer
have to have separate code
paths for inflating
the initial views
and then updating
the views later.
If we invoke the function
with an appropriate name,
then we'll get text, hello
world, on the screen.
When the data changes, we
can invoke the function again
with the new data
and the new data
appears with a new
greeting on the screen.
Each time we invoke the function
with different data, the text
on the screen is updated.
But what exactly is Compose
and how does this work?
Among other things, Compose
is a completely new set
of widgets and
toolkit APIs built
on top of composable functions.
They're not views.
They're not fragments.
They're something smaller, more
modular, easier to work with,
and easier to test in isolation.
Compose is also a
Kotlin compiler plugin,
which makes it possible to
define your own declarative
functions using our
declarative API.
The Compose compiler is
what powers the new widget
set and makes it easy for you
to define your own composable
widgets.
Compose widgets are also fully
compatible with the existing
view system.
Whether you're working with
Kotlin or the Java programming
language, we
provide ways for you
to use the new widget set in
your existing view hierarchy,
and you can use existing views
in the Compose hierarchy.
You can mix and match, you
can adopt it incrementally
and you can adopt it at your own
pace, just like Kotlin itself.
It's also very early stage.
We're still in
active development,
and we're moving to ALSP
so that you guys can
get an early preview
and so that you can be
a part of its development too.
So we can collect
feedback from you,
but it's not ready for
production use yet.
If you did want to use
Compose in an application,
it might look
something like this.
You can call composable
functions directly
from the content
of your activity.
All composable
functions are annotated
with an @Composable annotation.
This tells the Composer
compiler that your function
should be treated as a widget.
And it allows us to jump in and
perform the necessary rewrites
at the right time.
We've been working
with the JetBrains team
to make all of this possible and
it's still very experimental.
But basically, we intercept
calls to composable functions,
and that's what allows us to
provide the declarative API.
Ultimately these
functions are fully
featured Kotlin functions,
which allows us to do
some really interesting things.
For example, if we wanted
to greet the user 10 times,
we could use a simple for
loop to do exactly that.
If we want to iterate
over a list of names,
we can greet a whole bunch
of people all at once.
We can also have logic to show
something completely different
when the list is empty.
But the most important thing
about composable widgets
is that they're composable.
Compose makes it trivial to
define your own composable
functions and reuse them
throughout your application.
Your UI hierarchy
is built by having
composable functions call
other compatible functions.
ADAM POWELL: So our story
widget here uses several stock
elements that we're going
to provide out of the box
to build up a pretty
straightforward layout,
but you might see
another issue here
if you're not suspending
disbelief quite enough looking
at our slide wear here.
So as we know, if
that list right there
is really, really
big, then this would
create a whole lot of
these story widgets
that we're not going to see.
As Android developers, we've
been trained over the years
to avoid this.
In fact, I think
about 10 years ago,
Romain and I gave our
first talk together
where we were talking
about list view.
So this today would be the
job of a recycler view, kind
of our list view two widget
that you're all probably
familiar with.
But that means that we have
to factor out an adapter
to handle the recycler view
itself requesting and rebinding
those views.
So as you probably
know, there's really
no good way to fit a recycler
view adapter onto a slide.
It's a lot of code
even in the best case,
and I'm using data binding
to cheat a bit here.
And several things just
aren't shown at all,
like the diff callback for
helping to handle animations
on data set changes.
And we certainly
don't have anything
about event handling in
here, but you kind of
get the basic idea.
So let's come back to this loop
in the Jetpack Compose version
and see what else we can do.
Well, this is Kotlin after all.
We can define a generic
composable function that
looks like a for each loop
by using a trailing lambda
argument and have it emit each
story widget as it's asked for.
So what we did here is we
just defined our recycler view
adapter in one line of code.
So the implementation
of the scrolling
list itself can be just as
smart as a recycler view.
The body that we pass to
a composable function call
can itself be a
computable function lambda
so that scrolling list
can choose to call it
multiple times or not at all.
Much more powerful than
just passing parameters
through an include tag since
it means the scrolling list
doesn't need to know anything
about what we're going
to put in there when we use it.
You can put entirely
different structures
in here just depending on
code that you're running
and defining.
So we can do some other
kind of neat things too.
We can offer some
really powerful hooks
into our runtime for lifecycle
and subscription management
that can work
together seamlessly
with things like live data, RX
Java or the new Kotlin flows.
So up until now, we can do
most of what we've shown
here just with a clever DSL.
But here, observe will return a
new value each time it changes
and cause the news feed
function around it to run again.
So that'll feed new data
to our scrolling list
much like a recycler view
adapter data swap will.
So observe as shown here is
just defined in library code.
There's nothing special here.
There's nothing that
we've implemented
that's based on internal API.
You can write your own, too,
if you have your own favorite
observable or callback types.
So what else does
this imply about how
the scrolling list must work?
So let's go ahead and
put it into something
a little bit more sophisticated.
So we saw with
observing a live data
that we can trigger a
recomposition when something
changes.
So let's use an async
loading function that
can give us a
placeholder immediately
but the result of running
some sort of lazy loaded block
once it's actually completed.
So all of these sorts of
complex image loading scenarios
that we're all
familiar with suddenly
become something very simple
that we can use anywhere.
And also like we saw
with the scrolling list,
we can weave data across
layers of the hierarchy,
and they don't have to be
direct tree children either.
It doesn't matter
what kind of chrome
or how many layers of hierarchy
that card or column might
add in between in
order to do their work.
So we can go further than
we can with something like
data binding, and we can write
a whole lot less wire up code.
We can just use the lexical
scope of that image or story
that we already have, and we
can refer to the story headline
several layers deep.
This is really
part of what helps
make composable
functions composable,
how they're kind of
getting their name.
We can leave this as is.
I mean, it's a lot
of code for a slide,
but it's not a lot to
glance at an editor.
Or we can just use our
normal tools that we've got
and highlight extract
method on any part of it
and go ahead and generalize it.
This isn't anything magic.
It's just the same
tools and techniques
that we're already used to
doing when we're writing code.
So we've talked about how we
can observe changes in live data
and we've seen how we can show
place holders while we request
a data load from somewhere else.
But what if we get an update to
one of our story data objects?
So our story data that we
use as a parameter in there
is really most
naturally represented
as a Kotlin data class.
There's really nothing
too special about it.
But we'd like to be able to
update our UI if anything
about it changes.
What if this was mutable?
So if it were a fragment, we
might use an arch components
view model with some
live data as properties
and use the same technique
that we saw earlier.
But this is going to get really
repetitive really quickly,
especially with all that
extra subscription management,
we're kind of deciding
where all of this goes.
Really we just wanted to write
that code from the last slide,
and you can.
So Composer's compiler plug-in
lets you mark a data class
as a model which make the
properties observable when it's
used in a compose function.
Now, if our story
changes, the story widget
that read its fields
will know to recompose.
The Compose runtime
observes the changes
and will cause the story widget
function to rerun and update
our UI with the new data.
JIM SPROCH: When you're
generalizing your code
like that, it's really
important to break it up
into multiple
compatible functions
and understand how the data
flows through your application.
The application passes data--
in this case, a
list of stories--
into the news feed.
The news feed is then
going to iterate over
this list of stories,
extracting each
of the pieces of story
data from the list
and passing one story
data to each story widget.
The story widget then
reads the title, the image,
and the content
from the story data.
The important thing here is that
the parent is always in control
of the data for the child.
If the data needs to be shared
between multiple widgets,
the data should be hoisted
up to a common ancestor
and passed down to each of
the widgets that needs it.
Children should not be
reading from global variables
or global data stores.
They should be a
side effect free
and should not do
anything except what
the parent tells them to do.
As your application
scales, this architecture
makes your code much
easier to reason about.
But what happens if the
application wants to know
when a user clicks on a story?
One interesting pattern
is to pass lambdas down
because code is data
which allows us to have
events propagate upwards.
It looks something like this.
In this case, the news feed
takes an unselected lambda,
which is going to take
in some story data, which
is the current story.
It will then, when the news
feed invokes the story widget,
it's going to take
this lambda and create
a new lambda of its own and
pass that lambda to the story
widget.
The story widget then
passes that lambda
to a clickable widget, which
will respond to the click.
When a user clicks on the story,
clicks on the clickable widget,
the unclick will fire
which will cause the event
to propagate back up
to the lambda that
was created and passed in.
This lambda will
call unselected,
which is the lambda that
was passed to the news feed
by the application.
So the parent is
always in control.
The data-- in this case, the
lambda-- is being passed down,
and then the event
bubbles back up.
If we look at this
in diagram form,
we see that the application
starts with some data,
passes it down to the news
feed, which passes it down
to each of the story
widgets, which in turn pass
the information down to the
composable building blocks that
build up each widget.
Then when a user clicks
on a piece of the widget,
that triggers an event which
calls the lambdas going back
up the hierarchy,
back up to the screen.
Ultimately the application can
then update the applications
data model and the
new data will be
passed back down all
the way down until it's
displayed onto the screen.
Notice that the data was
always passed top down and data
always comes in as parameters.
The widget didn't have to
reference the activity.
It didn't do anything
except code that
was controlled by the parent.
We'll come back to this
with the Spinner example.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
So the Spinner has a problem
that the code that we just saw
doesn't in that the
Spinner makes you deal
with multiple sources of truth.
So our app has a state,
the Spinner has a state,
and the Spinner doesn't
ask us before letting
the user change its state.
That's the basic
shape of the problem.
And there's two ways to solve
this when you have this,
like one of these sides
must win if you want to have
a single source of truth.
So we could design some
of these components
such that the Spinner itself
is the source of truth.
And you could see how you
would put that together even
with the API that we just saw.
And it basically
looks like having
to add a whole bunch
of validation APIs.
It means that every
user interaction widget
needs these fully
formed APIs for anything
that you can change to sort of
filter through what you might
do in order to validate that
what the user's inputting is
actually correct.
And it scales kind of poorly if
you're writing those components
yourself.
You want to have a case where
it's turtles all the way down.
You want to make sure that it's
as easy to write a component
as it is to consume a
component, so you kind of
don't want everybody
to have to deal
with writing all their
APIs twice, writing
these sort of validation
filters for every property
that you can set.
So the other option
that we think
is better that we're
certainly pitching here
is to let the app
own its own data
and have the apps backing data
model-- the source of truth
that you're using
that's part of your data
repository be the
source of truth instead.
So this has a whole lot
of other advantages.
JIM SPROCH: Let's take a
look at a concrete example.
Here we have a food
preferences widget
that we define as a
composable function.
It takes in some
user preference data,
and ultimately it
will emit a Spinner
which has some set of options
that are available to the user.
Notice that the
Spinner's data is
set by the selected parameter.
So the favorite food of
the user is passed directly
to the Spinner.
The parent widget, in this
case food preferences,
is in control of what
the spinner is showing.
And when the spinner
has a user indicate
that they want to make
a change, the user
can then execute
the unchange code
which will result in
the data being updated.
The Spinner doesn't know
which data is being updated
or what to do, it
just calls on change.
When the data does get
updated, this Compose function
will get recoomposed and the
new selected value will be set.
We can apply the same
approach to text.
So in this case, we
have an editable text
for the user's name, and all
that the unchanged handler does
is set the name.
This looks pretty
generic and you
might wonder why the
editable text couldn't just
set the text itself.
But maintaining this
one-way dataflow
allows us to do some
really interesting things.
For example, if we have a phone
number preferences, then when
a new potential value comes
in, we can do filtering.
We can remove any
invalid characters,
and then we can format the phone
number so that it looks nice
when the user is typing it in.
And then we set the data model
to the new formatted phone
number.
Again, this will
trigger a recomposition
which will cause the editable
text to show the new value.
ADAM POWELL: All right, so
let's go ahead and go back
to some of our goals
from the beginning
that we listed through.
Did we actually meet
some of those goals?
And I kind of think we did.
So in order to meet
our unbundling goals,
we're open sourcing a new UI API
and component set for Jetpack
We've offered
computable functions
that scale across these
layers of abstraction.
A composable function
can do the same sorts
of jobs as a fragment or
as a custom view group
or even as something as
small as a single button.
We've kind of established this
guideline of one-way observable
dataflow as a
first class concept
and we're building the system
to make it easy to sort of stay
on this happy path.
And finally, you have
less code and you
can keep it in one place.
You don't have to split your
focus across multiple files
just to write a
piece of your UI.
JIM SPROCH: OK, that
was a lot of information
in one short talk,
and we're only
just scratching the surface.
Some of you look
excited and others
might have a lot of questions.
For example, what about
view compatibility?
Will this work with
the existing views,
and how do I integrate
this into my application?
So one of the things
that you can do
is have a annotation
that indicates
that this code should be usable
from within a Android view.
And when you do that, it
will generate a view class.
This class is just
a standard view
like any other from your
code possible function.
And you can use it from
XML, as shown below,
or you can call
the find view by ID
and get a reference to the
node and pass data directly
to the view.
There's other things that
might be interesting to you.
For example, we've been
giving a lot of thought
to how Layout Editor and
Preview Tool would work.
We've been giving
a lot of thought
to animation, styles, themes,
and constraint layout.
All of these things are
really important to get right
before we go with
a stable release.
And so we're going to make
sure that we have support
for everything that
you would need to build
beautiful applications.
And we're still thinking
about a lot of other things.
We're continuing
this exploration.
We have ideas around
multi-threaded layout,
around asynchronous
parallel execution
of composable functions, around
memoization, and much more.
All of these things
become feasible because
of the declarative
programming model,
and we encourage you to start
exploring these ideas with us.
We'd love to hear your ideas.
ROMAIN GUY: All right just
want to make one clarification.
You saw an example
of Jetpack Composer
that was using a Spinner.
We don't have a spinner yet,
and it be called Spinner.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM POWELL: How
are people going
to understand what to use?
ROMAIN GUY: But if
you really want one,
you can build one,
that's the whole point.
Yeah, so I just want
to reiterate that here,
one of the key
elements is-- well,
two key elements that I really
love-- first, composition.
If you go look at the
source code in AOSP,
you can look at how some of
the widgets were implemented
and you'll see they
are that simple.
You start to write
some code, but you
should look at the
checkbox, for instance, it's
just a few lines of code,
and everything it uses
is available to you
to create your own.
The one-way data flow model
is also really important
because a lot of the bugs and
a lot of the [INAUDIBLE] plate
in your code comes from
trying to keep two data
models in sync at all time.
And I mess that up all the time,
and I'm sure you do as well.
So we just got rid of
the problem altogether.
So Jetpack Composer is
not ready to ship yet.
We've established that.
Please go take a look
at the source code,
if you go to
d.android.com/jetpackcompose,
we have explanations.
We have a readme that
explain how the source
tree's architectured.
You can run a special version
of Android Studio that will let
you play with it, compile it.
We have a few demos
that are available.
You can look at the
entire source tree.
But in the meantime,
you can get ready
before this becomes available.
So one thing you can do
is just play with it,
but you can also try to
structure your application
to try to fill this
one-way data flow model.
So one thing you
can do already is
try to eliminate
all the [INAUDIBLE]
you have because every time
you do this, it's almost a
[INAUDIBLE].
Especially if you
called get on the view,
that means you're
trying to synchronize
the data model of the
view with the data all
of your application.
And this is a potential
source of bugs.
And you won't be able to do
this anymore in Jetpack Compose
because your functions,
your composables,
just emit a new tree.
At no point can you get a handle
on the actual, not physical,
but the actual new view object
that will be put on screen.
So you need to get rid of this
habit like basically right now.
Also you can start looking
at architecture components.
How many of you are
using the arch components
in one form or another?
All right, you are all awesome.
Everybody who didn't raise their
hands, run back to your desk
and go fix that please.
So you have several things
you can use like ViewModel
and LiveData, but there are
also other solutions out there,
so please try to use those.
And now we have a
few minutes left,
so here's the URL
that you can check out
if you want to know more, if
you want to find a source tree.
[MUSIC PLAYING]